じゃあ何が問題なのかって言うと、多分
システムが機能してないんだと思うよ。お
客様は何を求めてらっしゃるんだろう?お
客様が求める品質。そこに対して話し合い
をしていく。守られた水は腐るんですよ。
あ龍にしか済まない。青木サの人生学
100回聞いたら豊かになる話。
今日の質問はWeb制作会社を経営する
40代です。意見を言いやすい職場と緩ん
だ職場の違いについてご相談です。弊社で
は上下関係にこだわらず若手でも意見の
出しやすいフラットな組織づりを進めてき
ましたが、その結果最近では責任の所材が
曖昧になったり、比率の緩みにつながり、
単なる慣れ合いやでもありな空気が漂した
。
トップダウンには戻さず自由な発言と組織としての緊張感を両立させたいのですが、どうバランスを取るべきでしょうか?青木社長の考える心理的安全性と緩みの境界性についてご教授くださいというご質問です。
なかなかこれはね、深いテーマだね。
ま、職場から恐れや不安を取り除くという
ことを私はずっと、ま、テーマに39年
経用してきました。
ま、恐れと不安というものがあると
アイデアも出てこなくなるし、それから、
ま、どこ見て仕事をするかっていうところ
で、その自分の仕事のクオリティよりも
その人に認めてもらうとか、そのボスのな
んだろうな、言うことを聞くとか、その
ある意味では作業型人材を育てることにも
なりかねないので、クリエイティビティ
つまり想像的に自由にですね、いつでも
正直にこう自分の考えを述べられるような
、ま、そういう職場環境を目指してきたの
で、ま、そういう意味ではこの方はそう
いうある意味で環境作りに関しては成功し
てるんだろうけれども、それがじゃ何が
問題なのかって言うと、多分システムが
機能してないんだと思うよ。人事制度とか
それからうん。ヶ月に1回のうちで言うと
目標達成に対するお互いのワントワの
ミーティングだとかそういうあのKPI
って言葉僕はあんまり使わないけれども
つまり目標からの逆算と何をいつまでに
成し遂げたのかっていうそのマイル
ストーンをきちっと置きながら段階追った
実現をして達成というその成し遂げると
いうところからちゃんと逆算した
プランニングだとか、そのチームでの
話し合いだとか、それがゴールから離れた
、パーパスから離れたなんかお互いの
コミュニケーション、居心地の良さに
ばっかり焦点を当てた組織運営をしている
からそうなってるんじゃないかなと。だ
からちゃんとゴールセッティングをするっ
ていうこととビジネスはサクセスなんで、
プライベートはハッピネスなんで、その
ビジネスにおける成果というものの最低と
それから自分たちの仕事の責任とお客様
からお金をいただく以上業界ナンバーワン
の貢献をどうしたらできるのかとかそう
いうところをもう少し話し込んでいくこと
も大事なんじゃないかなと。そんな風に今
感じましたけどね。ありがとうございます
。
ま、何のためにこのある意味を出しやすいフラットな組織作りをするかというと、ま、別に慣れ合いをするわけではなくて、もうゴールにたどり着くためにそれを実施するというこの順番がそもそも違うっていうことですか?
そういうことだよね。そしてなんだろう、
やっぱりこう絆とかフォアザチームとして
結束やっぱお互いのことがお互いの願望に
入れ合っているからこそ仲間のために仲間
のその足りないところもカバーして
あげようとかっていうやっぱりそれは関係
性から生まれてくることなので恐れとか
不安がある職場ではみんな利己的になっ
ちゃうんですよ。プラスアルファの努力を
しなくなるので、それは逆に言うと
マイナスなんですよね。だから不安や恐れ
は取り除くけれども、みんなでパーパスに
向かって目的目標に向かって力を合わせて
働くというそういうやっぱり組織文化を
情勢していかなければいけないと思います
。だ、なんか気をつけなきゃいけないのは
無責任な人間をいっぱい育ててしまうで
やってもやらなくても同じみたいな
ちゃんとした評価制度とかそういうものも
機能しなくなってるんじゃないかと。今の
ね話を聞く限りもう少しそういうとこ3
ヶ月に1回のきちっとした人事制度ま、
ワンで話し込みをしながらマイルストーン
もう1回言うけどねこの置いて達成を
しっかりと積み上げていくことが大事なん
じゃないかと思います。
今きちゃおっしゃっていただいたようなこう、ま、ある意味しっかりと責任を果たしてる人を評価し、そして、ま、ある意味無責任になってしまってる人を責任が果たせるようにこう起動修正していくようなワンワンをしていくということだと思うんですが、それをしていった時にやっぱりこうある意味の、ま、安心安全な空間と言いますか、ちょっと、ま、ルーズな空間も居心地が良かったという社員からするとちょっとこう医感が出てしまうのかなとも思ったりはするんですけども、それもし方ないものとして改革を進めていくことを優先した方が良いというイメージでしょうか。
あのね、何を優先するかだと思うんだけど
、やっぱお客様に対する誠実さ、お客様と
の約束を守ることを最上位にしなきゃいけ
ないと思うんですよ。だからお客様は何を
求めてらっしゃるんだろう?お客様が
求める品質。そこに対してお互いきちっと
話し合いをしていく。だからなんだろう。
守られた水は腐るんですよ。は青留にしか
済まない。ビジネスっていうのは経済活動
を基本とした人間集団なのでお金をお客様
からいただく以上はそれの何倍も貢献し
なければいけない。そういう意味において
は誠実さ、誠実さというものを大切にそこ
からぶれずにちゃんと話し込んでいく。で
、多少居心地の悪さがあるとしても、それ
は今度は仕事が終わった後の飲み会だとか
でコミュニケーションをしっかり取ったり
、仕事離れたオフ会の方でそれをカバーし
ていったらいいんじゃないの。うん。仕事
はやっぱり幻格な方がいいと思いますよ。
もうバランスを取りながら社員の欲求を
満たしながら仕事はもう価値を生み出す場
としてやっていくと思うけどね。
うちの会社ってどうなってる?でも実際早期から見て
そもそもアチーメントの場合はやっぱ達成欲が強い社員が多いのでこう見達成を許容してまで慣れ合いたい人はそんなにもそもそもいないのかなとはまず持って思っているのでみんなで達成していくことがそもそも仕事上でま、喜びという社員が多いので、ま、達成してでオフはオフで当然楽しみのが強い社員も多いのでそれはそれで楽しんでるのかなという風には思います。
で、達成できないと昇心昇格できない
システムにしてるからね。アチュメントは
みんなある意味でそのシステムは大やけの
約束なので仕組みを整えてると思うんです
よ。発展反栄というものは気合じゃないん
ですよね。どこを目指すかだと思うんです
よ。そのやっぱり上の追求という企業理念
、我が社は選択を元にした好品質の人材
教育を通して顧客の成果の想像に貢献し、
全社員の物信両面の幸福の追求と社会の
平和と繁栄に起与する。
これが我々の存在理由なので散歩用紙じゃ
ないですか?顧客の成果の想像全社員の
物信両面の幸福ね。社会の平和と反栄起与
するという目的から見て今のなり合いって
いうのは異質だよね。だからみんなおずと
そういう気分優先のマネジメントはしない
よね。理念型なので。そういうことだと
思いますよ。
それが文化なんじゃないの。だ、文化をどう作り上げていくかっていうのが経営の腕なんだと思うよ。
ま、奥長が今おっしゃっていただいたように、あの、ま、価値を生み出してる人が全倒に政党にこう評価される人事効果制度なので、
あの、ま、入者当時例えば価値はまだ生み出せてなかったとしても生み出せる自分になりたいなという欲自体は若手社員からもやっぱり育まれてきたのかなということはすごく感じました。
そうだよね。
そうだと思いますよ。だからやっぱり人を
育てるっていうことは責任ある人間を育て
るっていうことなんで、だから今の方ね、
ちょっとこれ注意しないとAランク人材が
やめてBランク、Cランクしか残らない
会社になっちゃいます。そしてBランク、
CランクしかいなくなっちゃうとBランク
、Cランクはもう1つ下のDランクの方が
扱いやすいって言ってどんどん衰退の法則
に入っちゃう可能性があるよ。僕はもうA
ランク人材しか選んでないので、結果
伸び悩んだとしてもAランク人材として
採用しているので諦めないんですよ。だ
からうちはそういうじゃ非常にある意味で
厳しい企業体かもしれないよね。上を
目指していく組織文化なので本当にいい
会社を作りたいと私は転志し持ってるので
いい会社っていい人材の集まりなので
そんななんかこう傷のめ合いみたいな会社
を作りたいとは全く思ってないですね。だ
からやっぱりトップ次第なんじゃないの?
うん。そう思いますよ。うん。
なんだまはっきり言ってね。さっきの格減
的な表現だけど守られた水は腐る。何を
目的にするかによって人が育つ組織になる
か人が育たない組織になるかまやっぱり
そこそこほどほどっていう組織文化って
いうのはあのいい加減はグッドなんだけど
いい加減はダメです。これをちょっと頭に
置いてもらっていい加減いい加減の組織を
作ってください。いい加減はダめです。
このニュアンス大事ね、やっぱり目的に
向かって責任ある人材を育てていき
ましょう。え、ありがとうございます。
あの、本当にいつも感謝しています。え、
是非ね、このYouTube聞いて
いただいて、え、何か感じることあったら
コメント欄に是非お願いします。あと、え
、新機能のハイプも応援してください。
あと、あの、高評価とチャンネル登録もお
忘れなくよろしくお願いします。
え、皆さんのチャンネル登録に励まされます。それではまた次回の
YouTube
でお目に帰りましょう。よろしくお願いします。今だとアチーメントはもうあの運動会をやってたり
社員で旅行に行ったり
うん。
仲いいですしあとはでもやっぱり達成欲もあるのお互いに仕事に対してはクオリティに対してはフィードバックしちゃうような
組織文化だなと私たちがもう入社した時にはそうなってたので
そういうイメージしかないんですが昔もそういう文化だったんですか?それとも社がこう調整をされながら作り上げてきたものなんですか?
いや、運動会ができるようになったのはある程度社員が増えたから運動会勝手にその社員が企画し始めたわけでしょ。
ただ昔は仕事終わったらもう毎晩飲みに
行ったりカラオケ行ったり仲良くしてた
ことは間違いないよな。だから仕事が
厳しい分、情というかやっぱりこう
サポートしたりだから飲みに行って
rig然的にそこで相談に乗ってあげたり
すごく手厚くま、飲み食いはまああ稲森
さんはよくコンパっていう風にね、あの
強ラを作られた稲森さんはコンパが大事
だっておっしゃるけど、ま、ある意味では
仕事離れ後の横軸の人間関係、縦軸の達成
だけじゃなく、横軸のリレーション、ここ
がやっぱり絆になってくんじゃないの。だ
から仕事時間はある程度みんな達成に
向かって権限学しながら本気でクオリティ
を追求するけど仕事1歩離れたらまあ
仲良くやるっていうのは
小人数の時から変わらないのかな。うん。
まあ、本当にユニークな会社だったような
気がするね。でも、まあ、今だからね、
本当にこう軽団にも入り、本当におかげ様
でホワイトになってきたけど、昔は創業
当時はブラックって言われてもそれを
プラチナブラックって言われるほど働いて
きた会社だからね。いや、本当にだから
小さな会社が大きく発展していくプロセ
スってやっぱり社長の熱意とかパッション
にみんな巻き込まれて一生懸命みんなで
頑張ってるんだよ。で、能力の高い人が
最初っから採用できないので能力の低さを
長時間労働でカバーしてきた。ま、そう
いう歴史があるよね。僕は。だから昔いて
ね、一緒に働いてくれた人にも本当に感謝
してます。ま、結果離職があったりね、
いろんなことがあったけれども本当にそう
いう時代を得て今のアチーメントになっ
てるということですよね。でも仲間を大事
にする文化は変わらないんじゃないかな。
うん。そんな風に思いますね。